[Musik]
katharina hennes letzte station war die
leichenhalle von bangkok sie waren aus
der schweiz in den west zum kameruns
gekommen um eine afrikanische königin zu
werden bevor sie mit 52 jahren starb
zurück bleibt ihr ehemann prinz muscle
das adlige paar hatte in armut gelebt
aber trotzdem irgendwie seine träume
wahr gemacht
katharina fand hier was ihr zuhause in
moosdorf gefehlt hatte wärme natur
familie ein kind was braucht es mehr im
leben davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
dieser heiße freitagmorgen der ersten
juni woche begann mit einer episode die
man komisch finden könnte wenn sie nicht
traurig werden und die ganz gut zu
dieser geschichte passt david von
unserer königin prinz matze ist wieder
mal pleite er hatte den billigsten
leichenwagen weiter breit gemietet und
prompt hatte diese eine panne nun sucht
massera hektisch nach einem
ersatzfahrzeug ein hindernislauf
wir haben ein problem sagt er afrika ist
schwierig
ich wollte den leichenwagen für
katharina holen ich komme an ich habe
schon bezahlt aber was ist los der wagen
ist kaputt und
was wir jetzt tun jetzt muss es sich
irgendwie durchwursteln sagte er und
anderswo einen wagen finden so ist
afrika hier kann alles passieren
wie immer klappt es dann doch und ein
ersatzwagen ist da es um 13 uhr die
leichen an die verwandten übergeben
werden
freitag samstag sonntag finden landauf
landab die beerdigungen statt sie dauern
drei tage und haben den charakter eines
volksfestes ein paar hundert gäste sind
nicht außergewöhnlich
teilnahme ist für viele pflicht denn
schließlich werden die ahnen weiter
unter den lebendigen sein
so findet denn die letzte fahrt der
königin in einer verbeulten occasion
statt die von europa hierher gefunden
hat
[Musik]
die fahrt führt zum anwesen des paares
wo sie bereits erwartet werden
solcherlei anteilnahme gehört zur kultur
des stamms der warme decke die auch nach
jahren noch im idealen trauern
um eine königin oh meine königin rufen
sie und es gibt fast so etwas wie einen
wettbewerb um die schönste trauer
die klageweiber hängen sich an den sack
und einzelne farben interesse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein solches begehren ist bringt manche
familie an den rand des ruins
300 stühle mussten gemietet werden bier
und verpflegung für jedermann doch ein
schönes begräbnis ist vor allem für
adlige familien wie die unseres prinzen
pflicht
nun liegt katharinas leiche in jenem
gästehaus das sie einst gebaut hatte die
dem aber noch kaum jemand gewohnt hat
wie bin ich frau die kleins clavister
die cousine des prinzen um eine schöne
seit gestern weine ich um dich
sie sei so stolz gewesen auf ihre weise
schwester aus der schweiz erzählt sie
roth habe katharina hierher geschickt
und habe diesen ort für sie ausgesucht
sie habe oft gesagt dass die wolken und
die hypo sie an die schweiz erinnerten
und dass sie nun eigentlich ebenso sehr
eine kamerunerin sei wie eine
schweizerin
doch was ist passiert dass katharina so
früh mit 52 aus dem leben geschieden ist
laut totenschein war es ein herzinfarkt
doch die kameruner schweizerin daniela
ip bezweifelt dass
[Musik]
er mal dauert das ist für giftiges
katharina hatte zwei tage vor ihrem tod
noch mit ihrer mutter in der schweiz
telefoniert und über
verdauungsbeschwerden geklagt doch
direkte hinweise auf eine vergiftung
gibt es eigentlich nicht die bedeutung
wie und ballett sie hatte vorher zu sky
gesagt ich gehe zur toilette dann hörte
ich zehn minuten nichts mehr
bei gute dann ein geräusch ich sagte
catalin geht es besser war sie sagte
nichts
sie hatte das licht im badezimmer
angezündet und saß auf der toilette
was ich nachschaute traf ich sie so an
wenig
die kündigung sei erst der schock war
das ein schock für sie morgen wieder
gummi natürlich ich habe nie jemanden
sterben sehen so nahe bei mir am
gleichen ort ich habe nichts verstanden
haben sie geliebt
wenn wir uns nicht geliebt hätten wäre
sie nicht zwölf jahre hier geblieben das
ist eine frage die man nicht stellen
sollte denn wir sind zusammen seit
2005 seit dem 13 dezember
und so hatte alles begonnen
2005 entdeckte die arbeitslose
verkäuferinnen im internet ein bild von
prinz marcel i sie verliebte sich in den
kameruner ohne ihn je getroffen zu haben
stolz zeigte sie ihre frisch gedruckten
visitenkarten
[Musik]
noch im selben jahr wanderte katharina
handy aus am flughafen von kamerun
fielen sich die beiden zum ersten mal in
die arme
im abgelegenen hochland wurde die
bernerin begeistert empfangen
mitgenommen hatte sie ihr ganzes
erspartes
inklusive pensionskassen geld
einen code und polygamie gehören hier
zum alltag
es macht ihn krank dass sie wirklich
einmal einige von vielen frauen sind
woche dass sie die einzigste krippe
am palast des königs in band stellt die
skulptur des verstorbenen königs robert
enke er hatte 150 frauen und über 750
nachkommen einer davon ist
der aktuelle könig muscles haut bruder
verheiratete die bernerin mit dem
prinzen
an der trauung nahmen auch katharinas
elternteil sie erfuhren dass ihr
schwiegersohn ii thronfolge wird er
bleibt ein prinz ohne palast mit einer
frau die sich immerhin königinnen
zehn monate später kam sohn rudolf tucek
sky zur welt das glück schien perfekt
doch in der beziehung zeigten sich
bereits erste risse
er selber habe keine probleme aber sie
verstehe ihn nicht
sie vergessen dass ein afrikaner sei und
sie vergessen dass er ein adliger sein
publikum
in der abgeschiedenheit wo das leben ein
tägliche existenzkampf ist schmiedete
katharina grosse pläne
[Musik]
zwei jahre später ein horrorerlebnis
fünf bewaffnete männer überfielen die
kleinfamilie in ihrem zuhause und
behaupten sie aus masala vergitterte
danach den eingang und legte sich eine
pistole zu und er begann zu trinken
immer wieder musste katharina ins spital
alleine wegen malaria ein dutzend mal
sie hatte würmer und dreimal starb sie
fast an blutarmut
dann ein weiteres drama mit ihrem sohn
flüchtete sie in die schweiz aus angst
vor ihrem ehemann
[Musik]
also aggressiv immer verbal
trotzdem zog es sie ein jahr später
zurück nach kamerun katharina hoffte
dass sich ihr prinz gebessert hätte sie
füllte einen container mit gebrauchten
möbeln um sie nach afrika zu schicken
ein weiteres kapitel im ständigen hin
und her so lebte sie auch wieder dort wo
sie dem glück so nahe war aber auch der
verzweiflung einige ihr vorhaben
verschwanden buchstäblich im meter hohen
gras so auch das geplante hotel
das nun fertig machen
aber kostet chaotischen alexander und
mireille band eintritt 6 sie haben ihr
kopf durchgesetzt und da sollen wir
machen ist
und so ernährte sich die familie von dem
was der boden hergab auch
selbstversorger ohne festes einkommen
total was getraut
ich will ganz fan
geschrieben was harmlos verglichen
die chill out of life
das tief
immerhin das gästehaus ist fast fertig
gebaut aber eben nur fast
das gebäude bröckelt vor sich hin und
bleibt die meiste zeit hindurch
ungenutzt für sky ein idealer zumutbar
die spielkameraden des jungen sind seine
haustiere
wächst zweisprachig auf seine mutter
krise mit ihm berndeutsch der vater
französisch
ja
[Musik]
jeden morgen fährt die königin ihren
kleinen prinzen in die knapp zehn
kilometer entfernt liegende schule das
auto kann sich die familie leisten weil
katharinas mutter in der schweiz ab und
zu etwas geld schickt
der kleine besuchte in der ortschaft
bank ag eine katholische privatschule
umgerechnet 100 franken kostet das
schulgeld pro jahr
[Musik]
seine mitschüler nennen ihn nur lieben
den weißen
die lehrerin hat sich verspätet in der
klasse mit den über 80 schülerinnen und
schülern herrscht ein ziemliches chaos
der lärm ruft den schulmeisterschaften
plan
seit einiger zeit haben die parole strom
fernsehen und internet die neuzeit ist
im bus angekommen
katharina ist auf facebook präsent und
hat zwei bücher geschrieben die mit
einer auflage von 40.000 exemplaren für
schweizer verhältnisse recht erfolgreich
waren
sie in afrika zwei
jahren völlig gange ja
was er sieht als einmal sieht dass du so
gut ich es kann ja aber ihr hattet rund
gemacht als romy dann sinn ist erfüllt
doch dann endete das leben der königin
abrückt und alle kamen um sie noch
einmal zu grüßen auch ross war dabei die
zweite frau die masse auf den wunsch von
katharina geheiratet hatte
warum wollte sie eine zweite frau
sie wollte nicht mehr alleine sein wenn
ihr mal zum beispiel in seiner rolle als
prinz irgendwohin musste sie wollte
jemanden der auf so hat sie mich
ausgewählt
sehr enge freundinnen
doch ohne katharina wollte roos nicht
beim prinzen bleiben und ging zurück zu
ihren eltern
katharina hinterlässt ihren zehnjährigen
sohn dieser weiß kaum was ihm geschieht
hast du die mama gesehen hast du gebetet
hast du schon gesagt bei mama wie das in
mama willst du nicht adieu sagen sagt
die tante
[Musik]
er will nicht nehmen die mama stehen er
will nicht toten
bruders war klein
ist verstört
[Musik]
was wäre mit skype passieren in der
zukunft ich entscheide doch nicht über
die zukunft von irgendjemandem aber sie
sind da fragte ja aber ich kann das
schicksal nicht bestimmen wer in der
schweiz sein oder hier das kommt drauf
an auch was
tun wie mir aufgenommen wird in der
schweiz re sich dort um ihn kümmern wird
wenn das nicht geht dann kann auch hier
bleiben
die erziehung wäre die nicht besser in
der schweiz sind das ist nicht sicher
hier sehen sie sie nicht aber es gibt
auch kamerunische intellektuelle die
sehr bekannt sind bis in die usa sogar
es ist letztendlich eine spirituelle
frage aber nochmals wenn ich will geht
er in die schweiz wenn nicht dann bleibt
er hier aber das wissen sie noch nicht
ich sage ihnen nochmals wenn im juli
jemand von seinem schweizer verwandten
herkommt großmutter großvater oder onkel
dann müssen wir das alles ganz genau
besprechen
ich bin nicht grundsätzlich dagegen dass
er in die schweiz geht überhaupt nicht
das wichtigste für mich ist nur eines
dass er in der schweiz nicht in einen
weißen heim kommt dann würde ich nein
sagen
jemand von der familie muss sich um ihn
kümmern von seiner schweizer familie
sky besitzt sowohl den schweizer wie den
kamerunischen pass nur leider sind beide
abgelaufen
sein onkel rudolf wird versuchen in
diesem sommer in die schweiz zu holen
vorausgesetzt allerdings die nötigen
papiere sind bis dann bereit
die beerdigungen sind so wichtig in
dieser kultur weil die verstorbenen die
ahnen weiterleben darum wer den knochen
und schädel in vielen fällen später
wieder ausgegraben und als fetisch mit
magischen kräften aufbewahrt doch was
wir nun ausgeht kommt er der fließend
deutsch und französisch spricht in die
schweiz oder nächster hierauf wort zu
hause ist wo er seine hunde hat und
seine spielkameraden
fragen dieser kompliziert sind wie
katharinas abenteuer zwischen hier und
dort
da
[Musik]
so wird denn diese geschichte die von
liebe und hass handelt von früchten und
standhalten weiter gehen und zwar im
leben des kleinen jungen und wer weiß in
jedem seiner kinder und kindeskinder
[Musik]
katharinas geschichte eine fußnote aus
der globalisierten welt möglich erst
dank dem internet das menschen
zusammenbringt die noch vor kurzem weit
voneinander entfernt waren so als lebten
sie auf anderen planeten
wo zum schluss doch noch ein happy end
nach den vorstellungen der familie wird
katharina seele weiterhin zur familie
gehören und von zeit zu zeit wird sie
sich zu wort melden dann nämlich wenn
die menschen tanzen trommeln und singen
dann besetzen die toten die lebendigen
und reden durch ihre zunge 9 katharina
du bist nicht tot
[Musik]